All right. This is what I'm going to do.
I'm guessing it's just like any other field, except
it's called formula. going to call it Total Tickets Sold.
Okay, return type. I'm guessing, since I'm just adding
numbers together, I'm not going to get a date or
anything, I'm going to get a number. I don't really
know what this checkbox business is, but I'm not
going to worry about it. options, decimal places. I don't
want any decimal places. These are integers,
my friend. 'Kay. 'Kay, this is a little
tricky. okay. General admission, tickets sold. And then
I'm going to add it. And just write plus.
>> You can. So if you didn't know what kind of operators you could
use, that insert operator there tells you
exactly the simple operations you can do.
>> Add, subtract, yeah makes sense. Okay. So general admission tickets
sold and it's using the Code E version, but we're okay with
that. I'm going to add that to VIP tickets sold. And I think that's
what I want. I'm just going to try this and see if it
works. Should I hit this check syntax? no syntax errors found, excellent, next.
>> So you made it visible to everyone, you're going to automatically
add it to the page and let's go look at a record.
>> This is the moment of truth.
When I click, on Cloudstock
hey, hey, alright. That's pretty cool.
>> That's awesome.
>> It's really getting smarter.
>>
[LAUGH]
>> Okay. an I'm going to just delete this
field as well, cause it's annoying me now.
>>
[LAUGH]